i'm kennedy i'm bill hemmer i'm sandra
smith and this is the fox news rundown
friday september 9th 2022 i'm jessica
rosenthal
60 days until midterms and things are
escalating with ads debates and tweets
all part of a fight for those
independent-minded voters as both sides
battle for power whichever party is
leading the conversation um they really
do need to offer people something and i
think that that's what they're going to
try to do i'm dave anthony
sunday marks 21 years since 9 11.
so we remember a terror attack people
vowed should never be forgotten
talking to the mother of a hero who
saved lives that day until he lost his
our young people
whether they were alive or not for 9 11
have to understand
what is out there in the world it is not
all come by it's it's not all a happy
place and i'm paul batura i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
today marks 60 days until midterms and
the general landscape has tightened
polling shows people are evenly split
between democratic and republican
candidates texas republican congressman
tony gonzalez told this podcast this
week that in mid-september we're going
to see house republicans roll out this
commitment to america and i think once
that gets rolled out you're really going
to see the house republicans not only
members but also candidates circle
behind that and really have a unified
message on what we're going to do when
we're in power some races in some swing
states are getting more tense
pennsylvania democratic senate candidate
john fetterman the state's lieutenant
governor is ahead of republican dr oz in
the polls but oz has been calling
fetterman out for refusing debates after
he suffered a stroke here's fetterman
struggling at the end of august at a
steelworker event what is wrong with
demanding for
an easy
safe
kind of
their
income retiring pennsylvania republican
senator pat toomey joined dr oz tuesday
at a campaign event in philadelphia it's
clear that he's being dishonest he's
either not as well as he claims to be
or he's afraid to be called out for the
radical policies he supports it's one or
the other fetterman has since said he
will debate dr oz sometime in october
fetterman happily campaigned with
president biden who's since gone on
offense with last week's speech in
philadelphia there's no question
that the republican party today is
dominated driven and
intimidated by donald trump and the
migrant republicans
and that is a threat to this country so
with two months left to go the question
is which pitch will work and how much
depends on the state or district you
live in there's been such fluctuation in
the polls
which issues are really driving people
are they driving democrats to
republicans where's the enthusiasm gap
shannon bream is the new host of fox
news sunday and now that the primaries
are almost completely wrapped you do
have these head-to-head matchups and you
look at some of the senate races and see
that for republicans it's looking much
tougher than they had hoped um to retake
the senate the house it seems that the
gop will hold there the gap appears to
be narrowing a bit but you know until
people get out there in those polls in
november and of course early voting um
we just don't know where the dust is
gonna settle
yep uh on that front we spoke to texas
republican congressman tony gonzalez for
this podcast this week
and we talked a bit about how
republicans plan to sort of regain a bit
of that momentum that they appear to
have lost and he said the gop is going
to coalesce around this quote commitment
to america that they're going to roll
out in mid-september there's been a
little bit of buzz but i guess it's
going to get bigger in like a week or so
it's their midterm pitch and i'm just
wondering
what do you think something like that
should look like or feel like especially
after president biden's speech
and follow-up tweets he's made um really
criticizing and going after what he
calls maga republicans
yeah i think that uh house republicans
primarily under the leadership of kevin
mccarthy are going to launch something
that for those of us old enough to
remember newt gingrich's contract with
america and republicans are now saying
they think it's very important to give
americans something to vote for
instead of just trying to get them to
vote against democrat policies or
democrat candidates and i think that's
important you know whichever party is
leading the conversation they really do
need to offer people something
and i think that that's what they're
going to try to do down the down the
home stretch here they're going to say
all right here are our principles about
the economy about your family about
foreign policy and this is what we
promised to do for you so we are you
know that's been one of the criticisms
of republicans sometimes they make a lot
of broad sweeping promises they take
power and the people that voted for them
expect more than what they end up
getting so i think mccarthy and
republicans are very aware of that and
especially since there's been some
wobbling in the polls over the you know
abortion issue and some other things
i think they know that they need to get
out there and say these are our four or
five core policies this is what we
promise you we're offering you
alternatives from what you have right
now and i think you're going to see a
very big push in the next week or so to
really try to get that into the
bloodstream
let's talk a little bit about a couple
of senate races that are pretty big on
the radar the dr oz john fetterman race
in pennsylvania things are getting i
guess more tense there and some new
articles have come out this week about
john fetterman's health as we all know
he had a stroke one op-ed that i read
said that dr oz is handling the
criticism in a childish way this was
this op-ed this author but then pivoted
and said fetterman really does need to
get on the debate stage or be more
forthcoming
about his health struggles time frame on
recovery
we know the pennsylvania senate race is
one that people are really closely
watching it's a it's considered you know
the balance of power is 50 50 right now
so what's your take on some of the takes
on john fetterman it's been so
interesting it's very difficult i mean
anybody who's come back from something
that is that challenging physically
knows it takes time and it seems that
the word from his doctors has
continually been listen if he sticks
with the protocol and the healthy
lifestyle that we've discussed with him
he's eventually going to be fine but
when you're voting right now for
something that is a six-year commitment
people want to hear and see him he says
i'm out there i'm meeting with
pennsylvanians i'm in these local events
and people are seeing me well some of
the videos coming out from some of those
events make people a little bit
concerned about where he is in this
recovery process even if he's eventually
going to get back to 100
so there's this big debate over the
debates will they have them um both
these candidates have their pluses and
minuses for sure in pennsylvania and one
of the things the fetterman camp
continues to harp on is that you know oz
is sort of a carpetbagger and that he's
not really connected to the people of
pennsylvania that he's out of touch and
it's really tricky because you've got a
medical doctor who is running and saying
listen i understand the the fallout from
a stroke and what that entails and the
demands of being a senator and so i gosh
i think it's so tricky for both of these
candidates it's one of those really
unusual things that happen right in the
middle of the heart of these campaigns
and tough to navigate but as you said
there have been op-eds out there and not
from right-leaning us supporting kind of
organizations now saying okay we've got
some serious questions that fetterman
the candidate needs to answer let's talk
about new hampshire briefly that's
another one that's considered
you know key to the balance of power in
the senate we know democratic senator
maggie hassan is considered one of the
most vulnerable senators running a lot
of money in this race and on tuesday
we're going to find out who she will
face
among republicans brigadier general don
bulldock a more trumpy candidate if you
will or state senator chuck morse he's
um i guess considered the more moderate
new hampshire leans blue it might be
purplish but it leans blue
and i i want your thoughts it's sort of
reminding me a bit about how the
analysts are now saying like maryland
and massachusetts governor's races are
now lean democratic because the more
trumpian candidate is the republican
nominee if republicans don't do well
with the candidates they pick
do they shift or do you just say look
these are north east states that we're
talking about here they're more blue
anyway
gosh you know so much nuance to races
like this and the president former
president will tell the success that
he's had and we track how he does with
his endorsements they're very successful
in the primaries but the real test is
going to be whether you get someone
across the finish line in the general
and that's where there's been so much
you know speculation and criticism of
you know the former president and of
republicans and are they divided and is
mega running the show or the more
moderates running the show but you do
have to think specifically about each of
these states each of these races they
have their own personality and voters
who have their own sensibilities and so
it'll be interesting to see what happens
in this primary in new hampshire um
because you know if the former president
can keep going around racking up
endorsement wins in the primaries um
there are a lot of folks saying if you
don't win in the general what's the
point and that's going to be one of
those very tricky races in new hampshire
because like you said
definitely doesn't lean red it's purple
at best for republicans and certainly
leans blue and that means the general
the candidate that this gop puts up
makes all of the difference yeah
let's talk about trump he had a week
you've had some weeks
you've seen some of the criticism right
a trump appointed judge a federal judge
allowing a special master to help weed
through all the documents that were
found at mar-a-lago some have said you
know that's going to slow things down
namely the doj attorneys that it's not
needed and that it assumes the doj can't
do the job or wasn't maybe totally
justified here
just with you're our legal eagle right
you've covered supreme court you know
legal cases
where are your thoughts about where this
is going i guess maybe in the in the
short term
i'll be surprised if doj doesn't
appeal that ruling from the judge down
in south florida appointing the special
master
i would expect them to do that
listen if they're not successful on that
point it's really going to slow down
what the doj is doing with respect to
investigating the former president it's
not that they can't continue with the
investigation but they can't use the
documents that they took from mar-a-lago
as a basis for any of that investigation
as long as there's a special master
looking through those materials both
sides are supposed to cough up to the
judge their recommendations for a
special master hard to believe they
would agree on anything but the judge
will have to pick someone those
recommendations from both sides are to
be in by friday
so i i will be very surprised if doj
doesn't appeal that decision so all of
this is just kind of delaying what's
eventually going to happen
you know we just don't know what we
don't know yet in this case yeah marco
rubio was on fox news channel and he was
talking after the washington post
article came out about the material of
like the highest sensitivity about a
foreign country's nuclear program being
kept at mar-a-lago he said that the
leaking of that kind of information
that can't really be refuted is a huge
problem and it's just political to
influence the narrative um
what do you make of that does he have a
point like if you're not worried about
your case do you even leak
well and that's a tricky thing is that
the doj has been in court arguing
against releasing information in this
case and that of course it ties the
hands of the trump legal team there's
only so much they can do without full
exposure to this information and like
you said when these leaks come out it's
very hard for them to respond to that in
any substantive way because this is you
know people speaking off the record on
the condition of anonymity people who
know people familiar with the
investigation
it's a real conflict that they need to
get a handle on and critics left right
and center are saying that about you
know doj either stop the leaks or open
up and be more transparent about what
you have and finally um shannon preview
your show what's happening
we kind of had a framework in place and
now with the unfortunate news about the
queen we're certainly looking to add
voices thinking about the decades of
service that she has given
how she really has been so fundamental
to
um really the stability of western
society at some points you think about
through wars and assassinations and
popes and presidents and prime ministers
i mean this queen has been there as a
steady voice a steady hand
there's enormous love
for her and the way she devoted herself
to her country selflessly for decades so
we're looking at adding some guests to
our show that will
be able to tell us more about her and
really give her role in history a proper
context and perspective
we are also going to talk with senator
tim scott he is sort of out there as now
the voice of the republican party and a
number of big issues from police reform
to now this abortion debate his home
state of south carolina is
grappling with their state laws and how
they're going to handle that
and we will have full representation
from the democrats from the left side
they'll always have a voice at the table
so we're working with the white house we
hope to have an exciting announcement on
a guest from the white house very
shortly but certainly a number of
lawmakers and democratic candidates that
we're working with this week too and as
soon as we have that voice we'll
announce it and it is 9 11 and
of course we're going to memorialize and
commemorate as we always do each year as
americans the people we lost that day
the great sacrifices of heroes who ran
into danger that day and we've got
former new york yankees andy pettit with
us which i think is going to be really
interesting because if you'll remember
he was in the world series when
president bush 43 threw out that pitch
and the whole country at that moment was
united cheering for him as the person
who was leading us as commander-in-chief
through those dark dark days andy was
with him that day and we want to talk to
him about what that day was like how
sports can bring americans together are
we losing the ability to do that are
sports getting too politicized so
we thought that would be kind of a
unique take on the day so we look
forward to talking to andy too
love it shannon bream thank you so much
for your time you got it
[Music]
this is paul patero with your fox news
commentary coming up
there will be moments of silence on
sunday and bells will be wrong names
will be read remembering 9 11 21 years
of the world trade later
america was under attack that day we saw
a shadow it looked like a plane next
thing we know it was blooming when the
floor started shaking
and then we saw a debris fall down and
next thing we know we had to get out of
the building planes hijacked by
terrorists crashed into both twin towers
in new york city and those buildings
then collapsed
washington also got hit we had an
aircraft intentionally fly into the
pentagon a half hour after that a plane
believed headed to a dc target
crashed into a field near shanksville
pennsylvania the only thing you could
see was a big gouge in the earth and
some broken trees after passengers who'd
learned about the other planes being
flown into buildings fought back against
the hijackers on flight 93.
in the end nearly 3 000 people were
killed murdered by the 19 also dead
terrorists many other lives were saved
that day by first responders heroes who
didn't survive
in 2014 a 911 memorial museum opened in
new york city full of tributes to those
heroes and president obama at the
dedication ceremony spoke about one of
them they didn't know his name
they didn't know where he came from
but they knew
their lives had been saved
by
the man in the red bandanna that man was
wells crowther who worked in one of the
twin towers as a stock trader
wells was not only an equities trader he
was a fully trained volunteer
firefighter
allison crowther is his mother who
proudly tells us his story
wells actually we learned was preparing
to go over to help out at the scene at
the first tower the north tower the
first to be hit
and you know at that point i think
everyone was thinking it was an accident
or whatever but then of course that
there was a 17-minute
interval in between the first plane
hitting the north tower and then the
south tower which me and millions of
others we watched on live television you
know this that the plane actually hit on
live tv which was a you know complete
and utter shock he's actually in the
building so
you then
heard from him right a short time later
so it was after his tower was hit
and he said you know mom it swells i i
want you to know i'm okay i was at work
at the time in my office
just starting to hear about this i did
not hear my phone ring you know
communications were totally disrupted
that day yeah but at least we was able
to leave a message thank god we have his
voice recorded the story of what he did
was unknown to you
you just didn't hear from him anymore
that day correct and i'm certain that
over
as the hours built
when the tower went down you had a sense
of dread at that point
yeah as soon as i heard um
that this
the tower collapsed i knew oh
my heart of hearts i just knew wells was
gone so
i called my husband
sobbing and he said don't don't think
that don't say that he could have gotten
out i said how's that even possible
meanwhile what went on in between
we knew nothing
for months
our family needed a memorial service or
something we knew he wasn't coming back
so many families are still left with
that you know nothing which is a
terrible place to be
so we had a memorial service two weeks
after he was uh
after 9 11. it wasn't until march 2002
more than six months after the south
tower collapsed when crews finally found
wells crowther's body alongside the
south tower incident commander and other
first responders but the crowther family
still had no idea about all the lives
wells saved before losing his
until may i kept always
reading looking watching the
documentaries anything i could i was
trying to because something was driving
me
a mother's instinct who knows to keep
looking for my child for my son
and so my husband couldn't read anything
or look at anything he he just was so
bereft
911 killed my husband as surely as it
killed wells it just took a lot longer
so
memorial weekend of 2002
is when the big article in the new york
times came out called fighting to live
as the towers died and that my husband
said here you may want to see this he
couldn't even look at it so i took the
paper and i started reading it i
remember saying to myself if i'm ever
going to see anything about wells it's
going to be here so i started reading
this article and sure enough there it
was
two of the witnesses lin young and judy
wein
made references to this mysterious man
wearing red bandanna calling out you
know with a fire extinguisher putting
out fires saying there are people who
you can help there are those you cannot
help only help those that you can help
get up and follow me now so he was
basically said this person was basically
setting up a triage
so i said oh my god wells i've found you
why when when you see the red bandana
and you read that
why does it jump out at you
it's because when wells was a small boy
we were getting dressed for church and
we was wearing a little suit we always
dressed for church well said to his
father whom he emulated daddy can i have
a white handkerchief for my pocket like
you have else was probably about seven
eight years old
and so my husband said sure wells and he
went and pulled out a white handkerchief
and then he said i don't know why i did
but i just pulled out a bandana i pulled
out a red bandana so he folded up the
white handkerchief put it in wells's
breast pocket of his suit jacket and
said now well
this handkerchief that's for show don't
touch it just leave it right there
here's a bandana that's for bloat to
blow your nose from jobs okay
and so that's how it started and from
then on wells always carried a bandana
with him and and most of them were red
so he always had this red bandana
he had i assumed that he had it in his
office
yes he did and in fact one of his
co-workers said wells why do you always
have that red bandana with you and wells
picked it up and held it up and turned
to her and said with this red bandanna
i'm going to change the world that new
york times report was titled fighting to
live as the towers died detailing how
only a small group who were above the
plane's impact made it out alive
so she reached out to two of those
quoted ling young and judy ween who was
the first one to respond telling allison
there were about
18 survivors of this of the sky lobby
and they'd all stayed in touch and with
a group chat since that happened so she
reached out to lin young and ling
responded i sent photographs of wells to
them
and they identified him wow
and
wells
and and and they think that wells is the
reason they were alive i mean he he
saved them all
oh yes absolutely it's been confirmed he
saved 12 people at least out of there
were about 200 people in the sky lobby
waiting for elevators when the plane was
hit of those there were only eight there
were actually 19 survivors but one died
soon thereafter so only really 18
survivors and of those 18 wells saved 12
of them
so lin young was the first wells took
down and that's then there was a woman
he carried over his shoulder with the
group ling young was with oh and wells
had said to lincoln when they were up on
the 78th floor can you carry a fire
extinguisher we may need it going down
and she said yes she was burned over 40
percent of her body but god bless her
she's such a trooper so she carried the
fire extinguisher wells carried the
woman over his shoulder and other people
ling was with and down they went at
about the 61st floor
the air was clear lights were on uh
wells put the woman down and said you
have to go on from here i are there
other people i have to go i have to go
back up and help others ling told me
that she said to this woman he was
carrying come on i we have to go now and
the woman said i can't i'm too weak i
can't go
so she never survived but but lang and
the other people did and then he went
back up and of course the building
collapsed and then he was gone yeah well
he did go back up but he got all the way
back down because he was found with
donald burns the instant commander with
the fdny and his men and what we learned
later through fdny connections was that
that group was planning to go back up
and cut people out of elevators and do
whatever
and when the tower collapsed so wells
did get all the way down to ground level
but he wasn't he wasn't going to stop
trying to help
oh no he was never going to stop this
was wells he would do whatever it takes
and he would never stop if he survived
the collapse he'd be down there for
months trying to help
so that was well he just was
very tenacious
and he has since become one of the most
famous of all the 9 11 heroes there's
been a documentary and books about the
man on the red bandana and his family
has built upon his legacy with the wells
remy crowther charitable trust that
hands out scholarships and awards
there's also the red bandanna project
that fosters leadership teaching
programs at schools nationwide and at
wells alma maters nyack high school in
new york and boston college he's honored
in red bandanna themed sporting events
including a football game tonight in
nyack it's
incredible it just means the world to us
you know one of the very horrible
feelings i had when wells was first lost
was
well is that it i mean what happens to
wells now does he just disappear off out
of people's minds or
he was such a wonderful person
it was just such a flow and so terrible
to think that his life had been
extinguished and yet when this goes on
and
students still to this day they learn
his story they're inspired by him he's
very much alive in the hearts and souls
of these young people and that to me is
just an incredible thing his sister
honor wrote a children's book for very
young children called the man in the red
bandanna and that's been selling
wildly also for very young children so a
lot of these
incredible things have happened you know
you talk about this but it's 21 years
now
all of the students who are going to be
at these games
to them they weren't alive for it if
you're 30 and under 9 11 is a very
different experience for the
you know versus us who are adults
watching it on tv
and and all the aftermath and everything
about it
do you think that the stories are still
helping people not forget
i hope the stories are keeping it alive
it's
really very important piece of our
history is
one of the most devastating things
probably that's ever happened to have
civilians attacked at this level
our young people whether they were alive
or not for 9 11 have to understand
what is out there in the world it is not
all kumbaya it's it's not all a happy
place
but
your son's story and the story you
continue to tell at least it helps to
give people uh the hope
that there is there's there's good in us
that's the power of wells's story that
it gives a touchable example this was
not a rock star this was not a superhero
this was not a make-believe figure his
example was one of humanity
and love
and courage
fearlessness caring for others and
facing
horrible situations
undeterred to help other people
and that's how we can change the world
allison crowther the mother of
wellsgrather one of the 911 heroes known
as the man in the red bandanna we thank
you for your time we offer our
condolences thank you so much for
joining us thank you very much dave
one final note
the conversation i had with allison
crowther was longer than we could
include in today's rundown on sunday
when we mark 21 years since 9 11
we will include the entire conversation
in our fox news rundown extra
please come back check it out on sunday
[Music]
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as i take on american
life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download podcasts
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind the death of queen
elizabeth ii drops the curtain on the
longest reigning monarch in world
history at just over 70 years on the
throne elizabeth's remarkable tenure at
windsor castle in buckingham palace
spans 13 united states presidencies
dating back to dwight eisenhower but the
queen's reign wasn't just notable for
its sheer length and record number of
days in power
he was notable for how she spent those
years and how many lives she touched
throughout 96 years of her life
she was born elizabeth alexandra mary
she was known as a young girl with
beautiful handwriting who spelled well
loved history enjoyed music and even
spoke fluent french
unless you think she was perfect she
apparently struggled with arithmetic
elizabeth was in kenya in february 1952
when her father king george vi died just
like that she was queen
after a period of mourning and
preparation she was coronated in june of
1953.
as queen of england elizabeth
represented the monarch and her kingdom
through good times and bad
she was a consoler and a cheerleader she
served as a bridge between an emerging
post-world war ii europe and a
tumultuous fast-changing world
but beyond being drawn to the pomp and
the pageantry beyond the intrigue with
the richness of royalty what was it that
drew so many of us to the queen and her
extended brood
i think at the center of it all is our
deep and abiding desire for family and
stability
queen elizabeth represented that yes
there was the dysfunction and sometimes
it made unfortunate headlines
but more often than not the queen's
reign ran like a train traveling on time
through a beautiful picturesque
countryside she was reliable dependable
she also appeared unflappable and always
firmly in command
we all intrinsically want that we want
to be loved and we want someone to love
we're drawn to the security of loving
parents a devoted spouse children who
mean everything to us and hopefully we
mean everything to them
so what was the queen secret how did she
pull it off i mean 70 years
it really wasn't a secret at all
in message after message usually at
christmas she said her personal faith in
jesus christ was quote the anchor in her
life
she said in 2014
quote christ's example helps me see the
value of doing small things with great
love end quote
whether you're the queen of england or
living in queens new york it's usually
the little things that make the biggest
difference
the very best way to honor the memory of
queen elizabeth ii's long and storied
life is to love the people god has
placed in your life and on your path
god saved the queen for 70 years and now
because of her faith in him
she lives on with him in a world without
end i'm paul
batura you've been listening to the fox
news rundown rundown stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
new from the fox news podcasts network
my name is kennedy and welcome to my
podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome it's kennedy saves the world
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes